>> My name is Amar and I lead
Project Fiddle here at
Microsoft research.
My colleagues and
I are working on
speeding up distributed
Machine Learning jobs.
Our emphasis has been on
Distributed Deep Learning.
DNN models are
expensive to train,
not just in the amount of
resources they consume,
but also in the amount
of time they
take to train these DNN models.
So, the motivation
for these systems,
we have this new generation of
Big Data systems in
this generation of AI.
We have tasks such as image
recognition classification,
translation, and speech-to-text
and text-to-speech conversion.
There have been various solutions
that have been proposed
over the years.
So, I think the first
generation of solutions
like disbelief and Project Adam
looked at using commodity
computers to solve some of
these problems using DNNs.
In the next generation of
systems like TensorFlow
and Microsoft CNTK were
generalizations that
let the programmers
specify how to code
up these DNNs and solve many
of these stocks as opposed to
buying solutions
for specific tasks.
But the key factor
that still remains is
DNN training is extremely time
and resource consuming.
So, training jobs last days
to multiple weeks at times,
and there's this constant cycle
of train validate
repeat which blows up the
training time effectively.
One of the most important
things in this work
is naively
parallelizing this work
can actually be detrimental,
because what really matters
at the end of the day is
the quality of work or time
to reach a certain accuracy.
So, the problem that we're
trying to solve here
is we've set an ambitious
goal for ourselves,
we'd like to perform
100X more efficient training.
Intuitively, what
this means is if you
have a model that
takes an entire day to
train we'd like to train
this model in 15 minutes
over your coffee break.
The approach we take in
Project Fiddle is to cut
across the system stack.
So, we look at training,
the bigger picture
of training from
a single GPU all the way
up to multi GPU,
multi-machine clusters
across the system stack.
So, we look at
the memory subsystem,
we look at how to structure
computation across these
different computational units,
we look at the communication
infrastructure
so it's speeding up
communication which is
inherent in this workload.
Then finally, all
the way up the stack,
I've been talking about
these innovations
that help a single job,
but we look at sort of
multiple jobs all using
the same cluster running in
this multi-tenant
clustered environment,
and we were looking
at techniques to make
fault-tolerant elastic training
work on these clusters.
Let me take a very
specific example
to keep you grounded
in an example.
So, one of the projects, Gist,
looks at how much more can
we do on a single GPU?
So, before you ask for
your second GPU we'd
like to make sure
that you're maxing out the
capabilities of a single GPU.
So, let's move here
while I explain Gist.
The first thing to note here
is what I'm showing
you here is memory,
is a bottleneck for
even single GPU training.
So, sorted on
this X-axis we've sorted
different DNNs for
image classification
effectively sorted
them over time.
You'll note that
the memory consumed by
these different DNNs
over time increases.
We further dug deeper
and we wanted to find
out what in there is
consuming memory and the stuff
that's marked in red,
that's highlighted in red,
are the heavy hitters.
Those are the feature maps
that are stored
and needed for backward
computation during DNN training.
So, to explain this in
sort of an abstract way,
here's the representation
of a DNN layer,
you can think of
any layer taking as
input X outputting
some feature map Y.
Then in its backward pass
it's going to take
some output gradient
dy and output sort
of this gradient dx,
and dx is a function
of xy and dy,
it could be a function
of xy and dy.
So, to compute dx now,
we need to actually
store X and Y.
So, this is the abstract view
of what the layer does.
If you unroll this over time,
this is the same
representation of that,
we've unrolled it over time,
Li here takes as input X
and outputs Y and much
later in its backward pass
takes as input dy and outputs dx.
So if you just looked at
the lifetime of
this data structure X,
it's first generated here,
and then used here
and discarded here.
But we know better,
X is actually just used
in this time slot,
not used in this long gap,
and then used again here during
the backward pass of Li.
So, now we have an opportunity
here to take this data structure,
encode it, and hopefully,
have a succinct
representation of X.
In this long time gap relinquish
all the memory that X
was consuming and then
decode that encoded
representation
into a full-fledged
again when we need to do
backward computation.
So, just takes in
the original
computation graph for
a particular task
and statically for
every data structure augments
this computational graph
to have these encode
decode edges and
our memory manager
effectively manages
all these memory regions.
I was hand waving here when
I talked about encode and
decode functions,
but specifically,
we have a bunch of techniques,
both lossless and
lossy techniques,
that are used for these
encode and decode functions.
The higher order bit
here is using
Gist for these networks
we can get up to
a 2x compression ratio.
Encode decode of course is not
free for these
different networks,
there's a minimal overhead of
one to seven percent that we pay
for the same mini batch size.
But the beauty of Gist is we can
enable larger mini batch
sizes to be loaded,
and so with larger
mini batch sizes
will have faster training.
So, this was Gist which
is one extreme of
the spectrum making a single
GPU do more effectively.
Let me take you to
this other extreme
which is Multi-Machine Training.
So, parallel programming
is hard in general,
and I want to showcase why it's
harder parallelizing
DNN training.
So, for that let's move on
to this particular terminal.
I'm gonna skip ahead
a couple of slides
to get those slide where I
talk about parallel training.
So, let me talk about PipeDream
which is a new way to
parallelize DNN computation.
So, the most important thing to
note here is naive parallelization
can hurt DNN training.
Because if you naively
parallelize something
you might actually be
increasing the total time
for training because
total time of training depends
on two things time per
Epoch and the number of
Epochs for a given accuracy.
While you might
decrease the time per
Epoch you might be
increasing the number
of Epochs effective.
One of the predominant ways
of parallelizing
DNN is this thing called
data parallel training,
where you run multiple replicas
and these replicas communicated
with each other every so often.
If you aggregate
all the times for
compute and communication styles,
you notice this pattern
where there is
a bunch of time you're
spending just communicating.
So the problem there
of course is that of
hardware efficiency or
waiting for communication to
occur and you're not
doing any compute.
This is including optimizations
like wait freebie
back propagation,
but try to pipeline
communication and computation.
So, this was a fake graph let
me show you a real graph.
Here's different networks
image classification
RNNs that we tried out,
and one thing that
you'll notice is
as you increase
the number of workers,
let's just consider
one of those DNNs,
as you increase the number of
workers for a given GPU setting,
let's take K80s, for example,
you'll notice that
the amount of time that's
taken to communicate
these parameters
for parameter exchange,
is going up.
So, we're plotting communication
overhead as a percentage
of total time,
but what's worse is as you
start using faster compute.
So if you go from K80 to B100s,
your computer's going much
faster but the amount you're
communicating is still the same,
and so the communication
overhead shoots up dramatically.
The other approach
that's used for
parallel training is
a thing model parallelism,
where you take a model
and split it up across
sort of different GPUs.
This is most commonly used to
work on memory limitations
if you can't load
an entire model onto one GPU.
So, this is great and enables you
to at least train this model.
But there are
two major challenges one,
it's extremely hard for
the programmer to figure out
where to split this model,
this splits will vary not just
based on the DNN
that's being trained,
but also will vary based on
the deployment in question.
The second is that of
low hardware efficiency.
So, you'll notice
in this figure that
only one GPU effectively is
active at any given
point in time,
and all the other GPUs
are sitting
idle because of the nature
of this computation.
To do backward work at machine
one for mini batch one it
has to wait for
the work to go through all the
other machines and
come back to it.
So, the idea we have in PipeDream
is we're sort of
going to take a re-look
at model parallelism.
But not for memory limitations,
but instead for throughput.
We're going to use
this idea of pipeline,
so we're going to add
much more number of
jobs into the pipeline.
At the same time,
we'd like to have the programmer
not have to specify how to
parallelize this workload.
So, we have a tool that
automatically figures out what
the right parallelization
scheme is,
and then a runtime
that executes this and
the programmer is not involved
in this process at all.
So, the way this is done is,
I'm just going to skip to the
slide that talks about this,
we take a DNN Run,
run it through our Profiler.
This run is just on
one of the GPUs,
it doesn't have to run on
all the GPUs that you're
going to run this on.
It spits out a profile of
parallel times as well
as how much data is
communicated between layers.
Based on this information and
given the number of machines
that you want to run this on,
our optimizer can spit
out a configuration
for parallelization.
PipeDream combines model
parallelism, data parallelism,
and pipelining, and
the speedups that we
observe because of
this combined pipelining
is significant.
We get up to 5x speedup for
various tasks that you've
tried this out for,
be it image
classification or RNNs,
for example,
sequence-to-sequence models
that do video-to-text
transcription.
So, to wrap things up,
so in Project Fiddle
we're doing systems research
to speed up DNN training.
We take a broader view
of training from
single GPUs to multiple GPU,
multiple machine setup,
and the cut across
the system stack from
the memory subsystem to how
the structure computation
automatically,
to communication
that's inherent in
this training paradigm
all the way
up to fault-tolerant
elastic training
on shared multi-tenant
clusters. Thanks.